Donald Trump and Rudy Giuliani are
accused of plotting to sell presidential
pardons as Trump's time in the Oval
Office was winding down for the very
affordable price quite frankly in
context of two million dollars a piece a
former staffer says in a lawsuit we've
already discussed the uh outrageous
sexual assault allegations that are part
of this lawsuit from former Giuliani
Stafford Noel Dunphy earlier in the show
I now want to focus in on the
presidential pardon part there's a
Business Insider article that summarizes
this quite well on Monday Rudy Giuliani
was hit with a bombshell rape civil
lawsuit filed by a former staffer the
staffer alleged in the lawsuit that
Giuliani asked if she knew anyone who
wanted to buy a presidential pardon the
suit says Giuliani said he was telling
them selling them for two million
dollars splitting the profit with Donald
Trump
now
where do you even start with this we
have said many times over the last
months an allegation is made against
Donald Trump and it's written off as
obviously not believable and then
another allegation is made that is very
similar and another one and there are
records and lordy there are tapes or
whatever the case may be there are
already pre-existing allegations that
there were all sorts of different ways
that potential pardons were being
shopped and uh representatives were
bringing them to Trump and there were
rumors of what about some kind of
financial aspect to this and now there's
a lawsuit which says under penalty of
perjury that there was a plan between
Giuliani and Trump to sell pardons for
two million dollars a piece and to split
the money is this proof that that was
taking place no
is this proof that they did it and sold
any pardons it is not proof but it is
again corroboration of a pattern that
has been alleged from sources who have
no interaction with each other and don't
know each other now one of the most
important questions to ask here and it's
a fair question and it's a question that
we should ask is it explicitly illegal
for the president of the United States
to sell pardons the reason we have to
ask this question is one of the things
we learned during the Trump presidency
is that just because
there are things that Trump did or is
accused of doing that no former
president tried to do that is not a
guarantee that the thing Trump tried to
do is actually against the law and to
some degree one of the things that
Donald Trump exposed through his
presidency is that the checks and
balances and separations of powers that
the founders of the Constitution put in
place never expected or assumed that
there would be someone in power like
Trump who might try to circumvent them
but let's get to the question is it
explicitly illegal for a president to
sell pardons
my research is that it is not explicitly
illegal there is not an explicit
provision that says a president can't
sell pardons or can't receive benefits
in exchange for pardons benefits could
be all sorts of different things however
and this is where so many of these
issues get complicated there are legal
experts that have said even without an
explicit provision saying you can't sell
a pardon as president
you could indeed as a president selling
pardons be violating other federal laws
bribery you just because you're the
president and you're not explicitly
barred from selling pardons doesn't mean
you couldn't be charged with bribery uh
in accepting money for a pardon fraud
obstruction of justice obstruction of
justice is an interesting one imagine
that the president sells a pardon to
someone who's under investigation or
under prosecution by the justice
department
by pardoning them potentially
preemptively you are effectively
interfering with the administration of
justice because you're saying whatever
the facts point to whatever the justice
department justice department thinks
they have based on the facts and the
evidence
I'm issuing a preemptive pardon you're
interfering with the administration of
justice and thus it could be an abusive
power or obstruction of justice that all
being said those are not explicit
Provisions that make it illegal for the
president of the United States to sell a
pardon and this is we learn this time
and time again with Trump
we don't actually have strong enough
checks and balances many of us might
have assumed for a long time no one like
Trump will ever come to power so we
don't need to worry about some of these
checks and balances that aren't strong
enough well we very quickly learned that
we do need to worry about it we will see
where this goes stunning Blockbuster
stuff if you deal with anxiety or
depression you may have tried meditation
exercise diet changes therapy all of
which are important things to try there
is also a new treatment that we've been
talking about on the program for years
which for many people has been a game
changer and that is ketamine therapy the
research around ketamine therapy for
anxiety and depression looks very
promising which is why I'm thrilled
about our new sponsor mind Bloom mind
Bloom is the leader in at home ketamine
therapy having safely helped thousands
of people with anxiety and depression
it's delivered to your door it's done
from the comfort of your home and unlike
traditional talk therapy ketamine Works
quickly and doesn't have the unpleasant
side effects of traditional
antidepressants in a study of over 1200
mind Bloom clients 89 percent reported
improvements in their anxiety and
depression after just two sessions read
about the evidence for ketamine therapy
we've talked about it on the show it's
pretty remarkable stuff mind Bloom is
offering my audience a hundred dollars
off your first six session program
go to mindbloom.com Pacman use the code
Pacman the link is in the description